(upbeat music)
- Hi guys.
Okay, I have a secret obsession
and it is with stains.
No, in fact, I stand for stains
and the reason I messed that up is
because stan is a new word to me.
Apparently it means stalker and fan.
It was kind of originated by Eminem,
so I'm definitely going with it.
So I'm a stan for stains.
The bigger, the tougher,
the stickier, the better.
I'm a mom, so this was kind of perfect.
My passion works.
I love concocting the
perfect solutions, products,
combinations, treatments, methodologies.
Tools are very important.
Process is important.
So I asked some people to
send me in their stains
and then I'm going to help
them figure out how to fix it.
Let's see how this goes.
Okay, first, Julia sent us a video.
Take a look.
- Hi, Drew.
My name is Julian Morales, and
I'm from Chicago, Illinois,
and I need your help.
Girl, you have no idea.
I love to party.
I had a really great party,
but a couple of friends
of mine have spilled
some fruit punch on my carpets
and I'm supposed to be moving.
And my landlord said
he's going to charge me
if I don't get that stain up.
I have no idea how to get this out.
Drew, please, please,
please, please help me.
- Okay, first of all, Juliet, we both know
that that isn't juice.
And second of all, if it's really wine,
I need to know that because
it takes a different method,
but let's just pretend it's juice.
Here is everybody's first
mistake, in my opinion.
If you get stuff in your carpet,
do not leave it till the next day.
You want to have it be wet
because that's how the absorption happens.
Don't think, "Oh, I'll attack that later."
You won't!
It's set in at that point.
You can still fix it.
Make it a part of the party.
"Hey, I'm still grooving and talking,
but I'm doing this at the same time."
Okay?
The fun doesn't have to stop.
As far as I'm concerned,
the fun just started.
But seriously, don't think
that's a next-day project.
I'm not a righteous person,
but I'm kind of righteous about stains.
Don't push on it.
Lift.
Absorb.
You want to gently tap
a very absorbent thing.
When people go in and
start doing this, I'm like.
(Drew screaming)
So this, I am literally, I am like,
it's like a bunny's paw on cotton.
You're going to pat kind of
like you're the bunny going,
"Hey, I want some of that."
Like, "Hey."
Then you can take a
multitude of stain removals.
So I'm going to take my trusty Dreft.
Also, don't put a ton of stuff on a stain.
Be gentle with it.
It's like, think baby bunny
when it comes to stains.
How are we looking?
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
This is important to me.
I'm single.
I live with my two
children and how I party
and get off in my free time
is I kill stains, okay?
So if you have one, I'm
interested, all right?
I want to party.
Let's do this.
Michael, I understand you have a stain.
Show me what you got.
- Hey, Drew, my name is Michael Reddin.
I'm a real estate agent
from Whippany, New Jersey,
and I love eating ice cream.
Unfortunately, when I eat ice cream,
I get a little bit into it
and I wound up staining
my favorite white shirt
with chocolate ice cream.
I need to get this stain out.
I don't know what to do.
Drew, I need some help.
- Listen, it happens.
This is nothing.
Chocolate is nothing.
Again, this is why.
Yeah, that's right, the
Dreft is coming back out.
All right, now this time,
I'm going to treat the
Dreft very differently.
I mean, this is literally
finding your soulmate.
I'm not kidding.
I love you.
Oh, cherie.
You set my soul on fire.
That's what I do to my
daughter all of all the time.
It's from a "Tom and Jerry" cartoon.
And she goes, "Mom."
Probably 'cause, I don't know about you,
but I just live to embarrass my children.
So I'm just using my fingertip.
(Drew snorting)
(audience chuckling)
So at this point, if you want,
you can start to gently,
again, think bunny.
So I'm trying to make
this go a little faster
'cause we have a lot of other
things to accomplish today,
but I am in my happy place right now.
Here's another tip.
The fibers actually can
work as an abrasiveness,
so you can actually
start to rub it together
if you don't have a toothbrush handy.
Water in the bowl, excellent, okay.
This is pure water.
Ooh, it's warm too.
All right, now, normally I would put this
under a big running faucet, wring it dry,
and then present you with your shirt.
I want you to find that
chocolate, God darn it.
That's right, that's right.
Bring me your stains.
I want the challenge.
This is my happy place, bring it on,
what have you got for me?
Look, maybe I need to go get
a life, but you know what?
I don't care.
I love stain removal.
I do stan for stains.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)